d'écouteurs sans fil dernière génération
ses petits chouchous bandana petit
boîtier avec les écouteurs à l'intérieur
nature et ses produits on les retrouve
partout sur les réseaux sociaux et
notamment dans les stories des
influenceurs qui font bénéficier leurs
communautés d'offres attractives mais
dans certains cas ces articles on peut
les retrouver en quelques clics sur
d'autres sites internet
vendu bien moins cher revendre en ligne
des produits proposés et stockés par
d'autres plateformes
ça porte un nom le drop shipping les
produits est plus commun
de drop shipping les classiques les
montres les bijoux les bracelets
vraiment des trucs où ça peut donner
l'apparence de un côté luxe mais en fait
c'est du toc c'est du plastique c'est du
glacier pas de bonne qualité est allé
les fameuses peluche poulpe récemment et
les projecteurs au plafond étoilé
c'est un produit qu'on peut trouver à 10
15 euros sur l express pour les sorties
de série comme mandat lauriane etc
il ya des bébés yoda partout bref quand
il allait aux gros moment où il ya de
quoi faire du produit dérivé du faux
produits dérivés l'aller dropship heures
ils passent par les influences ans parce
que ça marche super bien
ces produits sont souvent acheté pour
quelques euros sur d'autres géants du
web comme ali express ou encore wisches
et revendus jusqu'à 10 fois plus cher
le drop shipping est tout à fait légale
en france le problème c'est qu'ils
flirtent vraiment un pied d'égalité sur
un peu beaucoup de points le mensonge au
niveau du produit souvent
ils embellissent forcément le produisit
ce coup c'est un produit de bonne
qualité produit avec des experts ou je
ne sais quoi fabriquer en france et à
aix-en-provence très exactement en
france aix en provence
il me semble avoir au moins cher quelque
part ah bah oui toujours su rallier
express il met aussi en avant le fait
que le produit soit unique alors qu'il
ne l'est pas du tout la politique de
retour des produits n'est pas du tout à
ça n'est pas du tout pris en compte pour
beaucoup de sites de drop shipping
en fait la plupart du temps c'est des
produits qui valent leur prix original
donc sur à l'express et tout ça sur
riesch
donc pour leur prix c'est des produits
de bonne qualité mais le problème se
situe sur le prix que hull et dropship
heure fixe parce que quand tu achètes un
produit 30 40 au tu t'attends à un
produit quand même d'une assez bonne
qualité certes un drop supports vont
jusqu'à développer leur propre marque en
modifiant le packaging des produits
[Musique]
pour se faire connaître sur les réseaux
sociaux il dispose de deux outils les
publicités ciblées et les influenceurs
entre 18 et 30 ans qui vise donc c'est
les plus actifs sur les réseaux sociaux
et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on voit la
plupart du temps des produits drop
shipping
dans cette tranche d'âge là parce qu'on
est les cibles on élit cible en fait de
ces produits là grâce à certains sites
comme shopi fayoux drop easy vous créer
sa boutique en ligne
ça ne prend que quelques minutes sur
internet il existe de nombreuses
formations fendu plus ou moins cher
certains formateurs sont même devenus de
véritables gourous pourtant faire du
drop shipping
ça n'est pas forcément rentable créer
une boutique en ligne c'est très facile
n'importe qui peut le faire c'est sa
demande rien en compétence tout effet
automatiquement avec shopi faille mais
le problème c'est qu'il faut un minimum
si connaître au niveau du target dans
les camps or influenceurs qu'on fait des
campagnes de pub faut bien s'y connaître
faut savoir où visé quand tu as un
produit en tête et ça y'a pas tout le
monde qui sait le faire donc si tu
investis quelques centaines d'euros en
pub et que derrière tes pas rentable a
beaucoup qui sont à voir et qui perdent
de l'argent derrière c'est ceux de pure
poste qui vous faut jeûner recevoir et
le son est juste incroyable
[Musique]